but we're going to begin with an
alarming warning from law enforcement
after the fbi search of former president
trump's mar-a-lago home for classified
information now there's been talk on
social media and other platforms of
planting a dirty bomb and even civil war
as the political fight over the search
escalates some lawmakers are now asking
for more information about how damaging
trump's removal of the documents from
the white house might be for national
security jeff because has more on that
part of the story from washington
i myself have been notified by the
bureau that
my life was put in danger former fbi
agent turned pennsylvania congressman
brian fitzpatrick appearing on face the
nation
after the fbi and dhs joint warning was
released on friday
among the threats was a plot to place a
so-called dirty bomb in front of fbi
headquarters as well as online posts
calling for civil war and armed
rebellion the bulletin capped off a
tense week for the nation's top federal
law enforcement agency an armed man was
shot and killed after trying to breach
security in an fbi field office in
cincinnati still the former president
posted on sunday great simmering anger
after agents carried out a search
warrant to recover classified government
documents from mar-a-lago they didn't go
in there with fbi raid jackets they
tried to constrain
their behavior carrying out that warrant
release court papers reveal that more
than two dozen boxes with 11 sets of
classified documents were recovered by
federal agents some of which were
labeled top secret after trump lawyers
attested in writing back in june
that all classified material had been
returned from the estate so the fact
that they were in an unsecured place
that is guarded with nothing more than a
padlock or whatever
security they had at a hotel
is deeply alarming clearly
no one is above the law donald trump is
not above the law and attorney general
garland is not above the law either his
actions are unprecedented in history and
he has a lot of questions to answer so
far no charges have been filed against
the former president but possible
charges include impeding an
investigation the removal of classified
national security records and violation
of parts of the espionage act according
to the search warrant
republicans are calling on the doj to
release the affidavit the affidavit in
support of the warrant
will give you the probable cause to try
to understand what is going on here and
i think the american people deserve this
democrat mark warner as well as
republican marco rubio both on the
senate intelligence committee both
calling for the release of the documents
in question as well as an assessment of
the type of damage to national security
mishandling those documents could do
nate
truly unprecedented times that's for
sure jeff thank you